- When I see stuff like this,
I see what's probably a teenager
headed down the wrong path.
So I decided to catch
a teen doing graffiti
and then warn his parents before he turns
to a life of crime.
To do this, I created a
series of fake promotional
posters for my TV Show
that may seem innocuous,
but to an immature vandal,
would be extremely tempting to deface.
To see which one would work best,
we left the posters up for a week
at several locations around
the City of Los Angeles.
To my surprise,
The Every Penny Counts poster,
Risk Equals Reward,
Tie Shoes For Safety,
and Be Flexible,
didn't attract any graffiti at all.
However, Dream Big and Stand
Up to the Big Guys did.
I decided to go with
Stand Up to the Big Guys
since there was opportunity for two dicks
and put it up on a wall
near a local high school.
I left a pen and added a
sticker that would make
the act even more irresistible
to an immature smart alec.
With all the elements in place,
I watched from a van across the street
ready to pounce at any moment.